at this altitude I can discover hello
boys and girls ladies and gentlemen this
is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show this
episode will share some of my favorite
advice and profiles from the audiobook
of tools of Titan's you heard that right
audiobook thousands of you have asked
for years for the audio book versions of
tools of titans and tribal mentors and
they are available today go to
audible.com slash Ferriss for more
details or to download either of them
today's episode will focus on tools of
titans and features the introduction of
the book as well as a few of my favorite
people profiles of Derek Siver's BJ
Miller and coach Christopher summer
shows you the breadth of expertise and
how different these profiles can also be
just a few notes on format I recorded
the introduction to the book and
selected three fantastic top-ranked
narrators to handle the rest along with
some surprise appearances from friends
of mine you might know the short BIOS
which you'll hear at the beginning of
each profile are read by Kaleo Griffith
ray Porter reads the bulk of each
profile including all of my words ray
actually narrated my first book the
4-hour workweek a lot of you love him
already
he did an incredible job quotations from
female guests are read by the wonderful
Torres Plummer the audiobook of tools of
titans contains the Distilled tools and
routines I've gathered after
interviewing hundreds of world-class
performers on his podcast everything has
been vetted and applied to my own life
in some fashion the techniques the
strategies and the philosophies and
tools of titans have made me more
effective saved me years of wasted
effort and frustration and have helped
me navigate quite frankly some very
difficult periods of my life many
periods of darkness and uncertainty the
advice has truly made me a happier
healthier person and changed my life I
hope the same for you please enjoy this
episode and if you'd like to listen to
100 Plus profiles and chapters from
tools of titans the audiobook just
to audible.com slash Ferriss listen to
this first how to use this book out on
the edge you see all kinds of things you
can't see from the center big
undreamed-of things the people on the
edge see them first Kurt Vonnegut
routine in an intelligent man is a sign
of ambition WH Auden I'm a compulsive
note-taker to wit I have recorded nearly
every workout since age 18 or so roughly
eight feet of shelf space in my home is
occupied by spine upon spine of notebook
upon notebook that mind you is one
subject it extends to dozens some people
would call this OCD and many would
probably consider it a manic wild-goose
chase I view it simply it is the
collection of my life's recipes my goal
is to learn things once and use them
forever
for instance let's say I stumble upon a
picture of myself from June 5th 2007 and
I think I really wish I looked like that
again no problem I'll crack open a dusty
volume from 2007 review the eight weeks
of training and food logs preceding June
5th repeat them and voila
end up looking nearly the same as my
younger self - the hair it's not always
that easy but it often is this book like
my others is a compendium of recipes for
high performance that I gathered for my
own use there's one big difference
though I never planned on publishing
this one as I write this I'm sitting in
a cafe in Paris overlooking the
Luxembourg garden just off of ruse st.
Jacques rue saint-jacques is likely the
oldest road in Paris and it has a rich
literary history Victor Hugo lived a few
blocks from where I'm sitting Gertrude
Stein drank coffee and F scott
Fitzgerald socialized within a stone's
throw
Hemingway wandered up and down the
sidewalks his books percolating in his
mind why no doubt percolating in his
blood I came to France to take a break
from everything
no social media no email no social
commitments no set plans except one
project the month and been set aside to
review all of the lessons I've learned
from nearly 200 world-class performers
I'd interviewed on the Tim Ferriss show
which recently passed 400 million
downloads the guests included chess
prodigies movie stars four-star generals
pro athletes and hedge fund managers it
was a motley crew more than a handful of
them had since become collaborators in
business and creative projects spanning
from investments to indie film and as a
result I'd absorbed a lot of their
wisdom outside of our recordings whether
over work outs wine infused GM sessions
text message exchanges dinners or
late-night phone calls in every case
I've gotten to know them well beyond the
superficial headlines in the media my
life had already improved in every area
as a result of the lessons I could
remember but that was just the tip of
the iceberg the majority of the gems
were still lodged in thousands of pages
of transcripts and hand scribbled notes
more than anything I longed for the
chance to distill everything into a
playbook
so I'd set aside an entire month for
review and if I'm being honest chocolate
croissants to put together the ultimate
cliff notes for myself it would be the
notebook to end all notebooks something
that could help me in minutes but be
read for a lifetime
that was the lofty goal at least and I
wasn't sure what the result would be
within weeks of starting the experience
exceeded all expectations no matter the
situation I found myself in something in
this book was able to help now when I'm
feeling stuck trapped desperate angry
conflicted or simply unclear the first
thing I do is flip through these pages
with a strong cup of coffee in hand so
far the needed medicine has popped out
within 20 minutes of revisiting these
friends who will now become your friends
need a reassuring pat on the back
there's someone for that an unapologetic
slap in the face plenty of people for
that too someone to explain why your
fears are unfounded or why your excuses
are
[ __ ] done there are a lot of
powerful quotes but this book is much
more than a compilation of quotes it is
a toolkit for changing your life there
are many books full of interviews this
is different because I don't view myself
as an interviewer I view myself as an
experimenter if I can't test something
or replicate results in the messy
reality of everyday life I'm not
interested everything in these pages has
been vetted explored and applied to my
own life in some fashion I've used
dozens of these tactics and philosophies
and high-stakes negotiations high-risk
environments and large business dealings
the lessons have made me millions of
dollars and saved me years of wasted
effort and frustration they work when
you need them most some applications are
obvious at first glance while others are
subtle and will provoke a holy [ __ ] now
I get it
realization weeks later while you're
daydreaming in the shower are about to
fall asleep
many of the one-liners teach volumes
some summarize excellence in an entire
field in one sentence as Josh Waitzkin
chess prodigy and the inspiration behind
searching for Bobby Fischer might put it
these bite-sized learnings are a way to
learn the macro from the micro the
process of piecing them together was
revelatory if I thought I saw the matrix
before I was mistaken where I was only
seeing 10% of it still even that 10%
islands of notes on individual mentors
had already changed my life and helped
me to 10x my results but after
revisiting more than a hundred minds as
part of the same fabric things got very
interesting very quickly for the movie
nerds among you it was like the end of
the sixth sense or the usual suspects
the red doorknob the [ __ ] Kobayashi
coffee cup how did I not notice that it
was right in front of me the whole time
you got the idea to help you see the
same I've done my best to weave patterns
together throughout the book noting
where guests have complementary habits
beliefs and recommendations the
completed jigsaw puzzle is much greater
than the sum of its parts what makes
these people
different judge a man by his questions
rather than his answers Pierre Marc
Gaston these world-class performers do
not have superpowers
the rules they have crafted for
themselves allow the bending of reality
to such an extent that it may seem that
way but they've learned how to do this
and so can you these rules if you want
to think of them that way are often
uncommon habits and bigger questions in
a surprising number of cases the power
is in the absurd the more absurd the
more seemingly impossible the question
the more profound the answers take for
instance the question that serial
billionaire Peter Thiel likes to ask
himself in others if you have a 10-year
plan of how to get somewhere you should
ask why can't you do this in six months
for purposes of illustration I might
reword that to what might you do to
accomplish your ten-year goals in the
next six months if you had a gun against
your head now let's pause do I actually
expect you to take ten seconds to ponder
this and then magically accomplish ten
years worth of Dreams in the next few
months no I don't but I do expect that
the question will productively break
your mind like a butterfly shattering a
chrysalis to emerge with new
capabilities the so called normal
systems that you have in place the
social rules you've forced upon yourself
the standard frameworks they don't work
when answering a question like this you
are forced to shed artificial
constraints like shedding a skin to
realize that you had the ability to
renegotiate your reality all along it
just takes practice my suggestion is
that you spend a real time with the
questions you find most ridiculous in
this book 30 minutes of stream of
consciousness journaling which we'll
talk about later could change your life
on top of that while the world is a gold
mine you need to go digging in other
people's heads to unearth riches
questions are your pickaxes and
competitive advantage this book will
give you an arsenal to choose from
performance-enhancing details when
organizing all of the material for
myself
I didn't want an onerous 37 step program
I wanted low-hanging fruit with
immediate returns think of the
bite-sized rules within these pages as
peds performance enhancing details they
can be added to any training regimen for
instance different careers personal
preferences unique responsibilities etc
to pour gasoline on the fire of progress
fortunately 10x results don't always
require 10x effort big changes can come
in very small packages to dramatically
change your life you don't need to run a
100 mile race get a PhD or completely
reinvent yourself it's the small things
done consistently that are the big
things for example red teaming once a
quarter Terra Brock's guided meditations
strategic fasting or exogenous ketones
etc tool is defined broadly in this book
it includes routines books common
self-talk supplements favorite questions
and much more what do they have in
common in this book you'll naturally
look for common habits and
recommendations and you should here are
a few patterns some odder than others
more than 80% of the interviewees have
some form of daily mindfulness or
meditation practice a surprising number
of males but not females over 45 never
eat breakfast or eat only the scanty
stuff air for example Laird Hamilton
Malcolm Gladwell General Stanley
McChrystal many use the chili pad device
for cooling at bedtime rave reviews of
the books sapiens poor Charlie's Almanac
influence and man's search for meaning
among others the habit of listening to
single songs on repeat for focus nearly
everyone has done some form of spec work
in other words completing projects on
their own time and dimed than submitting
them to prospective buyers the belief
that failure is not durable for instance
Robert Rodriguez or variants thereof
almost every guest has been able to take
obvious weakness
and turn them into huge competitive
advantages for instance Arnold
Schwarzenegger of course I will help you
connect these dots but that's less than
half of the value of this book some of
the most encouraging workarounds are
found in the outliers I want you to look
for the black sheep who fit your unique
idiosyncrasies keep an eye out for the
non-traditional paths like che Karl's
journey from manual laborer to YouTube
star to co-founder of a start-up sold
for nearly 1 billion dollars the
variation is the consistency as a
software engineer might say that's not a
bug it's a feature so borrow liberally
combine uniquely and create your own
bespoke blueprint this book is a buffet
here's how to get the most out of it
rule number one skip liberally I want
you to skip anything that doesn't grab
you this book should be fun to read and
it's a buffet to choose from don't
suffer through anything if you hate
shrimp don't eat the goddamn shrimp
treat it as a choose-your-own-adventure
guide as that's exactly how I've written
it my goal is for each reader to like
50% love 25% and never forget 10% and
here's why for the millions who've heard
the podcast and the dozens who have
proof read this book the 50 25 10
highlights are completely different for
every person it's blown my mind I've
even had multiple guests in this book
people who are the best at what they do
proofread the same profile answering my
question of what 10% would you
absolutely keep in which 10% would you
absolutely cut oftentimes the 10% must
keep of one person was the exact must
cut of someone else this is not
one-size-fits-all I expect you to
discard plenty
read what you enjoy rule number 2 skip
but do so intelligently take a brief
mental note of anything you skip perhaps
it's skipping and glossing over
precisely these topics or questions that
has created blind spots bottlenecks and
unresolved issues in your
that was certainly true for me if you
decide to skip something note it return
to it later at some point and ask
yourself why did I skip this did it
offend you seem beneath you seem too
difficult and did you arrive at that by
thinking it through or is it a
reflection of biases inherited from your
parents and other people very often our
beliefs are not our own this type of
practice is how you create yourself
instead of seeking to discover yourself
there's value in the latter but it's
mostly past tense it's a rear view
mirror looking out the windshield is how
you get where you want to go just
remember two principles
I was recently standing in place Louis
Aragon a shaded outdoor nook on the
river son having a picnic with writing
students from the Paris American Academy
one woman pulled me aside and asked what
I hope to convey in this book at the
core seconds later we were pulled back
into the fray as the attendees were all
taking turns talking about the
circuitous paths that brought them there
that day nearly everyone had a story of
wanting to come to Paris for years in
some cases 30 40 years but assuming it
was impossible listening to their
stories I pulled out a scrap of paper
and jotted down my answer to her
question in this book at its core I want
to convey the following number one
success however you define it is
achievable if you collect the right
field-tested beliefs and habits someone
else has done your version of success
before and often many have done
something similar but you might ask what
about it first like colonizing Mars
there are still recipes look at empire
building of other types look at the
biggest decisions in the life of Robert
Moses in the book the power broker or
simply find someone who stepped up to do
great things that were deemed impossible
at the time for example Walt Disney
their shared DNA you can borrow number 2
the superheroes you have in your mind
idols icons Titans billionaires etc are
nearly all walking flaws who have
maximized one or two strengths
humans are imperfect creatures you don't
succeed because you have no weaknesses
you succeed because you find your unique
strengths and focus on developing habits
around them to make this crystal clear
I've deliberately included two sections
in this book that will make you think
wow Tim Ferriss is a mess how the hell
does he ever get anything done everyone
is fighting a battle you know nothing
about the heroes in this book are no
different everyone struggles take solace
in that a few important notes on format
structure this book is comprised of
three sections healthy wealthy and wise
of course there's tremendous overlap
across the sections as the pieces are
interdependent in fact you could think
of the three is a tripod upon which life
is balanced one needs all three to have
any sustainable success or happiness
wealthy and the context of this book
also means much more than money it
extends to abundance and time
relationships and more my original
intention with the 4-hour workweek the
4-hour body and the 4-hour chef was to
create a trilogy themed after Ben
Franklin's famous quote early to bed and
early to rise makes a man healthy
wealthy and wise people constantly ask
me what would you put in the 4-hour
workweek if you were to write it again
how would you update it ditto for 4-hour
body and the 4-hour chef tools of
Titan's contains most of the answers for
all three extended quotes before writing
this book I called Mason curry author of
daily rituals which profiles the rituals
of 161 creatives like Franz Kafka and
Pablo Picasso I asked him what his best
decisions were related to the book Mason
responded with I let my subjects voices
come through as much as possible and I
think that was one of the things that I
did write often it wasn't the details of
their routine habits so much as how they
talked about them that was interesting
this is a critical observation and
exactly why most books of quotes fail to
have any real impact take for example a
one-liner like what's on the other side
of fear
nothing from Jamie Foxx it's memorable
and you might guess that the profound
underlying meaning I'd still wager you
to forget it within a week but what if I
made it infinitely more powerful by
including Jamie's own explanation of why
he uses that maxim to teach his kids
confidence the context and the original
language teaches you how to think like a
world-class performer not just
regurgitate quotes this is the key meta
skill we're aiming for to that end
you'll see a lot of extended quotes and
stories how to listen to the quotes one
of my podcast guests also one of the
smartest people I know was shocked when
I showed him his raw transcript Wow
he said I generally like to think of
myself as a decently smart guy but I use
past present and future tense like
they're the same [ __ ] thing it makes
me sound like a complete [ __ ]
transcripts can be unforgiving I've read
my own so I know how bad it can be and
the heat of the moment grammar can go
out the window to be replaced by false
starts and sentence fragments everyone
starts an ungodly number of sentences
with end and so I and millions of others
tend to use and I was like dot dot dot
instead of and I said many of us mix up
plural and singular this all works fine
in normal conversation but it can hiccup
for an audiobook quotes have therefore
been edited in some cases for clarity
length and as a courtesy to listeners
and guests alike I did my best to
preserve the spirit and point of quotes
while making them as smart and
listenable as possible sometimes I keep
it fast and loose to preserve the
kinetic energy and emotion of the moment
other times i smooth out the edges
including my own stammering if anything
sounds silly or off assume it was my
mistake everyone in this book is amazing
and I've done my best to showcase that
patterns where guests have related
recommendations or philosophies I have
noted that for instance if Jane Doe
tells a story about the value of testing
higher prices I might add listen to Marc
Andreessen since his answer to if you
could have a billboard anywhere what
would you put on it was
raise prices which he explains in depth
humor I've included ample doses of the
ridiculous first of all if we're serious
all of the time well we're out before we
get the truly serious stuff done
second if this book were all Stern looks
and no Winx all productivity and no
grab-assing you'd remember very little I
agree with Tony Robbins who's in this
book that information without emotion
isn't retained look up von restorff
effect and primacy and recency effect
for more science but this book has been
deliberately constructed to maximize
your retention which leads us to spirit
animals yes spirit animals there wasn't
room for photographs in the print
edition of this book but I wanted some
sort of illustrations to keep things fun
seemed like a lost cause but then after
a glass or four of wine I recalled that
one of my guests Alexis Ohanian likes to
ask potential hires what's your spirit
animal Eureka so in this audiobook
version you'll hear spirit animals for
anyone who had humor me and play along
the best part dozens of people took the
question very seriously
extended explanations emotional changes
of heart and Venn diagrams ensued
questions pour it in what a mythological
creature be acceptable can I be a plant
instead alas I couldn't get a hold of
everyone so these spirit animals are
sprinkled throughout the book like
Scooby Snacks
in a book full of practicality treat
these like little rainbows of absurdity
people had fun with it non profile
content and Tim Ferriss chapters that's
me in all sections there are multiple
non profile pieces by guests and yours
truly these are typically intended to
expand upon key principles and tools
mentioned by multiple people URLs
websites and social media I've omitted
most URLs as outdated URLs that means
website address are nothing but
frustrating for everyone for nearly
anything mentioned assume that I've
chosen wording that will allow you to
find it easily on Google or Amazon all
full podcast episodes can be found at
Tim
Blagh forward slash podcast just search
the guests name and the extended audio
complete show notes links and resources
will pop up like warm toast on a cold
morning nearly every guest profile I
also indicate where you can best
interact with them on social media
your send-off the three tools that allow
all the rest Siddhartha by Hermann Hesse
is recommended by many guests in this
book there is one specific take away
that navall rava khan has reinforced
with me several times on our long walks
over coffee the protagonist siddharta a
monk who looks like a beggar has come to
the city and falls in love with a famous
courtesan named Kamala he attempts to
court her and she asks what do you have
a well-known merchant
similarly asks what can you give that
you have learned his answer is the same
in both cases so I've included the
latter story here Siddhartha ultimately
acquires all that he wants merchants if
you are without possessions
how can you give siddharta everyone
gives what he has the soldier gives
strength The Merchant Goods the teacher
instruction the farmer rice the
fisherman fish merchant very well and
what can you give what have you learned
that you can give siddharta I can think
I can wait I can fast merchant is that
all Siddhartha I think that is all
merchant and of what use are they for
example fasting what good is that
Siddhartha it is of great value sir if a
man has nothing to eat fasting is the
most intelligent thing he can do if for
instance Siddhartha had not learned to
fast he would have had to seek some kind
of work today either with you or
elsewhere for hunger would have driven
him but as it is Siddhartha can wait
calmly he is not impatient he is not in
need he can ward off hunger for a long
time and laugh at it I think of
Siddhartha's answers often and in the
following terms I can think equals
and good rules for decision-making and
having good questions you can ask
yourself and others I can wait
equals being able to plan long term play
the long game and not miss allocate your
resources I can fast equals being able
to withstand difficulties in disaster
training yourself to be uncommonly
resilient and to have a high pain
tolerance this book will help you
develop all three I created tools of
titans because it's the book that I've
wanted my entire life I hope you enjoy
listening to it as much as I enjoyed
writing it Derek Siver's Derek Siver's
Twitter Facebook at civis Sybaris org is
one of my favorite humans and I often
call him for advice think of him as a
philosopher-king programmer master
teacher and merry prankster originally a
professional musician and circus clown
he did the ladder to counterbalance
being introverted derek created CD Baby
in 1998 it became the largest seller of
independent music online with 100
million dollars in sales for 150,000
musicians in 2008 derek sold CD Baby for
22 million dollars giving the proceeds
to a charitable trust for music
education he is a frequent speaker at
TED conferences with more than 5 million
views of his talks in addition to
publishing a 33 books via his company
wood egg he is the author of anything
you want a collection of short life
lessons that i've read at least a dozen
times
I still have an early draft with
highlights and notes behind the scenes
derek has read reviewed and ranked
ordered 200 plus books at sever's org
forward slash books they're
automatically sorted from best to worst
he is a huge fan of Charlie Munger
Warren Buffett's business partner and
introduced me to the book seeking wisdom
from Darwin to Munger by Peter beveling
he read awaken the giant within by Tony
Robbins when he was 18 and it changed
his life I posted the following on
Facebook while writing this chapter I
might need to do a second volume of my
next book 100% dedicated to the
knowledge bombs of Derek Siver's so much
good stuff hard to cut the most up voted
comment was from Kevin oh who said put a
link to the podcast and have them listen
it's less than two hours and it will
change their life Tim you and Derek got
me from call center worker to location
independent freelancer with more
negotiation power for income and
benefits than I previously imagined you
both also taught me the value of enough
and contentment and appreciation as well
as achievement that made my week and I
hope this makes yours 4-hour workweek
com forward slash Derek if more
information was the answer then we'd all
be billionaires with perfect ABS Tim
Ferriss it's not what you know it's what
you do consistently how to thrive in an
unknowable future choose the plan with
the most options the best plan is the
one that lets you change your plans Tim
Ferriss this is one of Derek's
directives which are his one-line rules
for life distilled from hundreds of
books and decades of lessons learned
others include be expensive expect
disaster and own as little as possible
who do you think of when you hear the
word successful quote the first answer
to any question is a much fun because
it's just automatic what's the first
painting that comes to mind Mona Lisa
named a genius
Einstein who's a composer Mozart this is
the subject of the book Thinking Fast
and Slow by Daniel Kahneman there's the
instant unconscious automatic thinking
and then there's the slower conscious
rational deliberate thinking I'm really
really into the slower thinking breaking
my automatic responses to the things in
my life and
slowly thinking through a more
deliberate response instead then for the
things in life where an automatic
response is useful I can create a new
one consciously
what if you asked when you think of the
word successful who's the third person
that comes to mind why are they actually
more successful than the first person
that came to mind in that case the first
would be Richard Branson because he's
the stereotype
he's like the Mona Lisa of success to me
honestly you might be my second answer
but we could talk about that a different
time my third and real answer after
thinking it through is that we can't
know without knowing a person's aims
what if Richard Branson set out to live
a quiet life but like a compulsive
gambler he just can't stop creating
companies then that changes everything
and we can't call him successful anymore
end quote
Tim Ferriss this is genius Ricardo
Semler CEO and majority owner of the
Brazil based Semco Partners practices
asking why three times this is true when
questioning his own motives or when
tackling big projects the rationale is
identical to Derek's four people
starting out say yes when Derek was 18
he was living in Boston attending the
Berklee College of Music quote I'm in
this band where the bass player one day
in rehearsal says hey man my agent just
offered me this gig it's like $75 to
play at a pig show in Vermont he rolls
his eyes and he says I'm not gonna do it
do you want the gig I'm like [ __ ] yeah a
paying gig oh my god yes so I took the
gig to go up to Burlington Vermont and I
think it was a $58 round-trip bus ticket
I get to this pig show I strap my
acoustic guitar on and I walked around a
pig show playing music I did that for
about three hours and took the bus home
in the next day the booking agent called
me up and said hey yeah so you did a
really good job at the pig show so many
opportunities and ten years of stage
experience came from that one piddly
little pig show we
your earlier in your career I think the
best strategy is to just say yes to
everything every little gig you just
never know what are the lottery tickets
end quote
the standard pace is for chumps quote
kemo Williams is this large black man a
musician who attended Berklee School of
Music and then stayed there to teach for
a while what he taught me got me to
graduate in half the time it would
normally take he said I think you can
graduate Berklee School of Music in two
years instead of four the standard paces
for chumps the school has to organize
its curricula around the lowest common
denominator so that almost no one is
left out they have to slow down so
everybody can catch up but he said
you're smarter than that he said I think
you could just buy the books for those
skip the classes and then contact the
department had to take the final exam to
get credit end quote
don't be a donkey Tim what advice would
you give to your 30 year old self Derek
don't be a donkey Tim and what does that
mean Derek well I meet a lot of 30 year
olds who are trying to pursue many
different directions at once but not
making progress in any right they get
frustrated that the world wants them to
pick one thing because they want to do
them all why do I have to choose I don't
know what to choose but the problem is
if you're thinking short term then you
act as though if you don't do them all
this week they won't happen the solution
is to think long term to realize that
you can do one of these things for a few
years and then do another one for a few
years and then another you've probably
heard the fable
I think it's Borodin's ass about a
donkey who is standing halfway between a
pile of hay and a bucket of water he
just keeps looking left to the hay and
right to the water trying to decide hay
or water hay or water he's unable to
decide so he eventually falls over and
dies of both hunger and thirst a donkey
can't think of the future if he did he'd
realized he could clearly go first to
drink the water then go eat the hay
so my advice to my thirty year old self
is don't be a donkey you can do
everything you want to do you just need
foresight and patience business models
can be simple you don't need to
constantly pivot Derek tells the story
of the sophisticated origins of seedy
babies business model and pricing quote
I was living in Woodstock New York at
the time and there was a cute tiny
record store in town that sold
consignment CDs of local musicians on
the counter so I walked in there one day
and I said hey how does it work if I
want to sell my CD here and she said
well you set the selling price of
whatever you want we just keep a flat
$4.00 per CD sold and then just come by
every week and we'll pay you so I went
home to my new website that night and
wrote you set your selling price at what
you want we'll just keep a flat $4 per
CD sold and we'll pay you every week and
then I realized that it took about 45
minutes for me to set up a new album
into the system because I had to lay the
album art on the scanner Photoshop it
and crop it fix the musicians spelling
mistakes in their own bio and all that
kind of stuff
I thought 45 minutes of my time that's
worth about $25 that shows you what I
was valuing my time out in those days so
I'll charge a $25 setup fee to sign up
for this thing and then ooh in my head
$25 and $35 don't feel very different
when it comes to cost $10 is different
and $50 is different but $25 $35 that
occupies the same space in the mind so
you know what I'm gonna make it $35 and
that will let me give anyone a discount
anytime they ask if somebody's on the
phone and upset I'll say you know what
let me give you a discount so I added in
that little buffer so I could give
people a discount which they love so $35
setup fee $4 per CD sold and then Tim
for the next 10 years that was it that
was my entire business model generated
in five minute
by walking down to the local record
store and asking what they do end quote
once you have some success if it's not a
hell yes it's a no this mantra of
Derrick's quickly became one of my
favorite rules of thumb and it led me to
take an indefinite startup vacation
starting in late 2015 I elaborate on
this later but here's the origin story
quote it was time to book the ticket for
a trip heed committed to long ago and I
was thinking oh I don't really want to
go to Australia right now I'm busy with
other stuff I was on the phone with my
friend amber rube arthas a brilliant
musician and I was lamenting about this
she's the one who pointed out it sounds
like from where you are your decision is
not between yes and no you need to
figure out whether you're feeling like
[ __ ] yeah or no because most of us say
yes to too much stuff and then we let
these little mediocre things fill our
lives
the problem is when that occasional oh
my god hell yeah thing comes along you
don't have enough time to give it the
attention that you should because you've
said yes to too much other little
half-assed stuff right
once I started applying this my life
just opened up end quote
busy equals out-of-control
quote every time people contact me they
say look I know you must be incredibly
busy and I always think no I'm not
because I'm in control of my time I'm on
top of it busy to me seems to imply out
of control like oh my god I'm so busy I
don't have any time for this [ __ ] to me
that sounds like a person who's got no
control over their life end quote
Tim Ferriss lack of time is lack of
priorities if I'm busy it is because
I've made choices that put me in that
position
so I've forbidden myself to reply - how
are you with busy I have no right to
complain instead if I'm too busy it's a
cue to re-examine my systems and rules
what would you put on a billboard
quote I really admire those places like
Vermont and Sao Paulo
Zil that ban billboards but I know that
wasn't really what you were asking
so my better answer is I think I would
make a billboard that says it won't make
you happy and I would place it outside
any big shopping mall or car dealer you
know what would be a fun project
actually to buy and train thousands of
parrots to say it won't make you happy
and then let them loose in the shopping
malls and super stores around the world
that's my life mission anybody in
anybody with me let's do it end quote
take 45 minutes instead of 43 is your
red face worth it quote I've always been
very type-a so a friend of mine got me
into cycling when I was living in LA I
lived right on the beach in Santa Monica
where there's this great bike path in
the sand that goes for I think 25 miles
I'd go onto the bike path and I would go
head down and push it just red-faced
huffing all the way pushing it as hard
as I could I would go all the way down
to one end of the bike path and back and
then head home and I'd set my little
timer when doing this I noticed it was
always 43 minutes that's what it took me
to go as fast as I could on that bike
path but I noticed that over time I was
starting to feel less psyched about
going out on the bike path because
mentally when I would think of it it
would feel like pain and hard work so
then I thought you know it's not cool
for me to associate negative stuff with
going on the bike ride why don't I just
chill for once I'm gonna go on the same
bike ride and I'm not going to be a
complete snail but I'll go at half of my
normal pace I got on my bike and it was
just Pleasant I went on the same bike
ride and I noticed that I was standing
up and I was looking around more I
looked into the ocean and I saw there
were these dolphins jumping in the ocean
and I went down a Marina del Rey to my
turnaround point and I noticed in Marina
del Rey that there was a pelican that
was flying above me I looked up I was
like hey a pelican and he [ __ ] in my
mouth
so the point is I had such a nice time
it was
purely Pleasant there was no red face
there was no huffing and when I got back
to my usual stopping place I looked at
my watch and it said 45 minutes I
thought how the hell could that have
been 45 minutes as opposed to my usual
43 there's no way but it was right 45
minutes that was a profound lesson that
changed the way I've approached my life
ever since we could do the math but
whatever 93 something percent of my
huffing and puffing and all that red
face and all that stress was only for an
extra two minutes it was basically for
nothing
so for life I think of all of this
maximization getting the maximum dollar
out of everything the maximum out of
every second the maximum out of every
minute you don't need to stress about
any of this stuff honestly that's been
my approach ever since I do things but I
stopped before anything gets stressful
you notice this internal aah that's my
cue I treat that like physical pain what
am i doing I need to stop doing that
thing that hurts what is that
and it usually means that I'm just
pushing too hard or doing things that I
don't really want to be doing end quote
on lack of morning routines quote not
only do I not have morning rituals but
there's really nothing that I do every
day except for eating or some form of
writing here's why I get really really
really into one thing at a time
for example a year ago I discovered a
new approach to programming my
PostgreSQL database that made all of my
code a lot easier I spent five months
every waking hour just completely
immersed in this one thing then after
five months I finished that project I
took a week and I went hiking in Milford
Sound in New Zealand totally offline
when I got back from that I was so Zen
nature boy that I spent the next couple
of weeks just reading books outside end
quote
what's something you believe that other
people think is crazy
quote oh that's easy I've got a lot of
unpopular opinions I believe alcohol
tastes bad and so do olives
I've never tried coffee but I don't like
the smell
I believe all audiobooks should be read
and recorded by people from Iceland
because they've got the best accent I
believe it would be wonderful to move to
a new country every six months for the
rest of my life
I believe you shouldn't start a business
unless people are asking you to
I believe I'm below average it's a
deliberate cultivated belief to
compensate for our tendency to think
we're above average I believe the movie
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world is a
masterpiece I believe that music and
people don't mix that music should be
appreciated alone without seeing or
knowing who the musicians are and
without other people around just
listening to music for its own sake not
listening to the people around you and
not filtered through what you know about
the musicians personal life end quote
treat life as a series of experiments
quote my recommendation is to do little
tests try a few months of living the
life you think you want but leave
yourself an exit plan being open to the
big chance that you might not like it
after actually trying it the best book
about this subject is stumbling on
happiness by Daniel Gilbert his
recommendation is to talk to a few
people who are currently where you think
you want to be and ask them for the pros
and cons then trust their opinion since
they're right in it not just remembering
or imagining end quote even when
everything is going terribly and I have
no reason to be confident I just decide
to be quote there's this beautiful Kurt
Vonnegut quote that's just a throwaway
line in the middle of one of his books
that says we are whatever we pretend to
be
end quote the most successful email
Derek ever wrote at its largest Derek
spent roughly four hours on CD Baby
every six months he had systematized
everything to run without him Derek is
both successful and fulfilled
because he never hesitates to challenge
the status quo to test assumptions it
doesn't have to take much in his below
email illustrates this beautifully
entered Erik quote when you make a
business you're making a little world
where you control the laws it doesn't
matter how things are done everywhere
else in your little world you can make
it like it should be when I first built
CD Baby every order had an automated
email that let the customer know when
the CD was actually shipped at first it
was just the normal your order has
shipped today please let us know if it
doesn't arrive thank you for your
business after a few months that felt
really incongruent with my mission to
make people smile I knew I could do
better so I took 20 minutes and wrote
this goofy little thing your CD has been
gently taken from our CD Baby shelves
with sterilized contamination free
gloves and placed onto a satin pillow a
team of 50 employees inspected your CD
and polished it to make sure it was in
the best possible condition before
mailing our packing specialist from
Japan lit a candle and a hush fell over
the crowd as he put your CD into the
finest gold lined box that money can buy
we all had a wonderful celebration
afterwards and the whole party marched
down the street to the post office where
the entire town of Portland waved bon
voyage to your package on its way to you
in our private CD baby jet on this day
Friday June 6th I hope you had a
wonderful time shopping at CD Baby we
sure did your picture is on our wall as
customer of the year we're all exhausted
but can't wait for you to come back to
cdbaby.com that one silly email sent out
with every order has been so loved that
if you search google for private CD baby
jet you'll get more than 20,000 results
each one is somebody who got the email
and loved it enough to post on their
website and tell all their friends that
one goofy email created thousands of new
customers when you're thinking of how to
make your business bigger it's tempting
to try to think all the big thoughts the
world changing massive action plans but
please know that it's all
from the tiny details that really thrill
someone enough to make them tell all
their friends about you end quote
at the end of life you can let a lot of
the rules that govern our daily lives
fly out the window because you realize
that we're walking around in systems in
society and much of what consumes most
of our days is not some natural order
we're all navigating some superstructure
that we humans created BJ Miller
BJ Miller Twitter ads an Hospice Zen
Hospice org is a palliative care
physician at the University of
California at San Francisco and an
advisor to the Zen hospice project in
San Francisco he thinks deeply about how
to create a dignified graceful end of
life for his patients he is an expert in
death through that he's learned how we
can dramatically improve our own lives
often with very small changes he is
guided or been involved with
approximately 1,000 deaths and he
spotted patterns we can all learn from
BJ is also a triple amputee due to an
electrocution accident in college his
2015 TED talk what really matters at the
end of life was among the top 15 most
viewed TED talks of 2015 don't believe
everything that you think this was BJ's
answer to what would you put on a
billboard he wasn't sure of the source
but attributed it to a bumper sticker by
the end of this profile you'll see how
BJ loves this type of absurdity
stargazing as therapy quote when you are
struggling with just about anything look
up just ponder the night sky for a
minute and realize that we're all on the
same planet at the same time as far as
we can tell we're the only planet with
life like ours on it anywhere nearby
then you start looking at the Stars and
you realize that the light hitting your
I is ancient some of the stars that
you're seeing they no longer exist by
the time that the light gets to you just
mulling the Barenaked facts of the
cosmos is enough to thrill me ah me
freak me out and kind of put all my
neurotic anxieties in their proper place
a lot of people when you're standing at
the edge of your horizon at death's door
you can be much more in tune with the
cosmos end quote
Tim Ferriss Edie Cooke does something
surprisingly similar and I've started
doing star therapy every night that I
can the effects are disproportionate to
the effort delighting in perishability
the following is BJ's answer to what
$100 or less purchase has most
positively impacted your life in recent
memory quote I would probably point to a
beautiful Pinot Noir from Joseph Swan up
in Sonoma County it's like the artwork
of Andy Goldsworthy or anyone who
delights in anything
ephemeral the charm in a bottle of wine
the craft all the work that goes into it
actually delighting in the fact that
it's perishable and goes away I find
really helpful I've gotten a lot of
miles out of a beautiful bottle of wine
not just for the taste and the buzz but
the symbolism of delighting in something
that goes away
end quote here's a good reason to
question your I cants be patient with
this and listen to the whole thing it's
worth it
Scuderia motorcycle dealership in San
Francisco also aided bj with his
seemingly outrageous mission Tim I hate
to focus on something perhaps
superficial but you just said riding
your motorcycle in passing now I
apologize if this sounds like a weird
question but you have three limbs that
have been damaged effectively amputated
how do you ride a motorcycle BJ you know
this was sort of a long dream that
recently came true
Tim congratulate
I mean it's fantastic I'm just so
curious about the logistics BJ thank you
well it's interesting you ask the man
who helped make this dream come true
Randy ended up being my patient and our
resident at Zen Hospice project not too
long after he converted my motorcycles
so there's a lot to this story my friend
I love two wheels
I love the gyroscopic lifestyle I love
the feeling of it and I've always loved
riding bicycles I'd always wanted to get
on a motorcycle but I kept going to
shops people would look at me and I
could never find a mechanic who was
willing to take it on and try to help
make it happen a fellow named Mert
lawwill who's an old motorcycle racing
champion sort of legendary in that world
happens to live around here Northern
California in Tiburon I don't know what
inspired Mert but he's a machinist
himself in a handy fella and in his
retirement he got into the business of
building a prosthetic component that
lends itself very well to mounting an
arm onto a bicycle or a motorcycle so
the first piece of this puzzle was
discovering mert's invention and getting
a hold of it myself which allowed me to
get my prosthetic arm attached to a
handlebar in a very functional way Tim
how are the hand controls modified BJ
Randy figured this out
Aprilia made a model the mana that is
clutchless this is essentially an
automatic transmission so do away with
the clutch & gear changes that's a huge
piece of the puzzle out of the way then
Randy figured out a way to splice the
brakes front and rear in a certain ratio
into a single lever so I'm doing nothing
with my prosthetic feet except holding
on to the bike I'm doing nothing with my
prosthetic arm except for holding on to
the bike all the action is in my right
hand brakes are one lever and then Randy
built this box and moved all the
controls the turn signals horn and all
that stuff over to the right side of the
bike at a good distance for my thumb to
reach them I have throttle brake lever
and then the turn signal box all
with one hand Tim that's so awesome
BJ that's it you know away you go
Tim I just have to pause here for a
second and just ask everyone listening
what [ __ ] excuses do you have for
not going after whatever it is that you
want please write in tell us on social
media why these are real excuses with
hashtag [ __ ] afterwards oh my god
man that's such a great story the
miracle of a snowball BJ described
waking up in a burn unit after being
electrocuted in college and losing three
limbs quote a burn unit is a particular
place a gruesome place the pain that the
patients are going through is
gut-wrenching working in a burn unit is
very difficult people usually don't last
in a burn unit very long as a clinician
the thing that often kills burn victims
after they've survived the initial
trauma is infection so burn units are
incredibly sterile environments
everyone's gound up masked and gloved
for the first several weeks I could only
have one person in my room at a time you
cut off from everything there's no day
or night there was no window in my room
even when people are at your bedside
there's all this garb in between you and
them you have no relationship to the
natural world
you can touch nothing you're also in a
fair amount of pain of course which does
not necessarily reward you're paying
attention to anything it's not fun
so that was November at some point in
December maybe it was early January
there were two nurses in particular I
felt very close to and it may have been
one of them who brought me the snowball
one was named joy of our cart apone they
may have been joy it was snowing outside
and I didn't know that she had the
bright idea of smuggling in a snow ball
to me so I could feel snow man it was
stunning what a simple little thing
right but she put it in my hand and just
feeling the contrast of that cold snow
on my sort of crisp burnt skin
the obnoxious inflamed skin and watching
it melt and watching the snow become
water the simple miracle of it was just
a stunner for me it really made it so
palpable that we as human beings as long
as we're in this body are feeling
machines if we're cut off if our senses
are choked off we are choked off
it was the most therapeutic moment I
could imagine I would never have guessed
this first of all the sensation just
holding that snowball but also the
implied inherent perspective that it
helped me have that everything changes
snow becomes water it's beautiful
because it changes things are fleeting
it felt so beautiful to be part of this
weird world in that moment I felt part
of the world again rather than removed
from it it was potent end quote
the power of bearing witness and
listening I asked BJ if you were brought
in as a physician or mentor to someone
who had just suffered nearly identical
injuries to yours what would your
conversation look like or what resources
reading or otherwise would you point
them to he replied with quote I think
I've gotten in trouble when I've tried
to come in with some predetermined idea
of advice giving oftentimes that's not
really what's needed it's more just the
camaraderie and bearing witness so to
answer your question when I do go into
folks rooms I'm there and I'll avail
myself to any questions they have but I
think most of the power of the visit is
just visiting just being together and
sharing this awkward body end quote
Tim Ferriss since chatting with BJ I've
noticed how this applies in many areas
to fix someone's problem you very often
just need to emphatically
to them even on social media or my blog
I've realized that people knowing you're
listening valuing them collectively is
more important than responding to
everyone for instance I sometimes put a
period before readers names when I reply
to someone on Twitter
eg period at widget that's a good
question the answer is so that everyone
sees the reply even though I can't
respond to everyone it shows I'm paying
attention to blog comments and at
replies it's a simple I see you if an
introverted hospice patient were to say
give me 1 to 3 things that I can watch
do absorb look at etc without human
interaction what would your answer be
quote I guess I'd put a picture book of
Mark Rothko paintings in front of them I
would probably put any music by
Beethoven into their ears and I probably
would reserve that third thing for
staring into space end quote
favorite documentary quote grizzly man
any piece of art where I'm not sure
whether to sob or laugh hysterically I
love that feeling where you just go in
either direction and you're not even
sure which is the correct emotion you're
simultaneously attracted and repulsed by
something that was my experience
watching that film so I think it's an
amazing piece of filmmaking and quote
sometimes cookies are the best medicine
for hospice patients at death's door big
existential conversations aren't always
the needed medicine one oddly powerful
alternative is baking cookies together
quote just the basic joy of smelling a
cookie it smells freaking great and it's
like the snowball you're rewarded for
being alive and in the moment smelling a
cookie is not on behalf of some future
state it's great in the moment by itself
on behalf of nothing and this is another
thing back to art art for its own sake
art and music and dance part
it's poignancy is its purposelessness
and just delighting in a wacky fact of
perhaps a meaningless universe and how
remarkable that is one way for all of us
to live until we're actually dead is to
prize those little moments end quote
advice to your 30 year old self quote
let it go I do mean to take life very
seriously but I need to take things like
playfulness and purposelessness very
seriously this is not meant to be light
but I think I would have somehow
encouraged myself to let go a little bit
more and hang in there and not pretend
to know where this is all going you
don't need to know where it's all going
end quote if the best in the world are
stretching their asses off in order to
get strong why aren't you Kristopher
summer
Kristopher summer Instagram Facebook add
gymnastic bodies gymnastic bodies calm
is a former US National Team gymnastics
coach and founder of gymnastic bodies a
training system that I've tested for the
last eight months no affiliation as a
world renowned coach summer is known for
building his students into some of the
strongest most powerful athletes in the
world during his extensive 40 year
coaching career coach summer took
meticulous notes on his training
techniques his wins and failures so that
he could translate the best elements
into a superior exercise system for both
high-level and beginner athletes his
four decades of careful observation led
to the birth of gymnastics strength
training GST spirit animal Falcon
backstory the combination of GST and
acro yoga has completely remodeled my
body in the last year I'm more flexible
in mobile at age 39 than I was at age 20
I'm going to skip explaining a lot Ichi
Maltese Stalder press handstand that is
best seen in video or pictures though
I'll describe the most critical Google
is your friend on working on your
weakness quote if you want to be a stud
later you have to be a PUD now end quote
coach first told me this when I was
complaining about slow progress with
shoulder extension imagine clasping your
hands together behind your back arms
straight then raising your arms without
bending at the waist
when in doubt work on the deficiencies
your most embarrassed by my biggest
weaknesses are shoulder extension and
bridging using the thoracic spine versus
lower back arch after improving them 10
percent over 3 to 4 weeks going from
making coach vomit to merely making
coach laugh a host of physical issues
that plagued me for years
completely disappeared to assess your
biggest weaknesses start by finding a
functional movement screen
FMS near you related from summer quote
you're not responsible for the hand of
cards you were dealt you're responsible
for maxing out what you were given end
quote
flexibility versus mobility summers
distinction between flexibility and
mobility is the most concrete and clear
I've heard flexibility can be passive
whereas mobility requires that you can
demonstrate strength throughout the
entire range of motion including the end
ranges see the J curl and pike pulse
exercises later for two examples of
mobility which can also be thought of as
active flexibility the pike pulse is a
particularly clear demonstration as it
tests compression strength in a range
that most people never experienced
consistency over intensity quote
slowdown where's the fire end quote
this is coaches constant reminder that
certain adaptations take weeks or months
of consistent stimuli if you rush the
reward is injuries in GST there are
surprising stairs
after long periods of zero progress
roughly six months into doing his
hamstring series with minor gains I
seemingly doubled my max ranges
overnight this was completely
unsurprising to summer quote I used to
tell my athletes there are stupid
gymnasts and there are old gymnasts but
there are no old stupid gymnasts because
they're all dead end quote
diet and exercise verses eat and train
coach summer dislikes the fitness
fixation on diet and exercise he finds
it much more productive to focus on eat
and train one is aesthetic and the other
is functional the former may not have a
clear goal the latter always does
they failed warm-up coach describing his
first ever seminar for non gymnasts
adults in roughly 2007 quote we've got
all of these beasts they're advanced
lifters and they're strong I tried to do
my entry-level plyometric group work and
some floor work with them the stronger
the athlete the faster they went down
knees lower back ankles from baby stuff
we're not talking anything hard we're
talking about standing in place and with
knees straight being able to bounce down
the floor using just your calves no way
their tissues couldn't take it they
hadn't done anything like it to show you
how bad mobility was we had 15 minutes
on the schedule to stretch nothing
intricate nothing intense just an easy
basic stretch get them loosened up for
the day that stretch took an hour and a
half to complete there were bodies lying
everywhere it was like I was in Vietnam
or filming a war movie I turned to my
staff and I'm like what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do now they failed warm-up
they failed
warm-up end quote why those Olympic boys
have gigantic biceps male Olympic
gymnasts don't have biceps the size of
their wastes from curls it comes largely
from straight arm work
especially Maltese work on rings but how
on earth can you practice a Maltese as a
novice I use a 50/50 pulley system to
cut my bodyweight resistance in half
which is similar to the ring thing power
monkey fitness or generic dream machine
that Jason Nemer loves using I combine
this with power levers strapped on metal
gauntlets that allow me to attach the
ring ropes to my forearms anywhere
between the elbow and the fists this
allows me to use progressive resistance
starting near the elbow and moving out
to the hand the best versions are
currently only available in Europe but
there are vaguely similar iron cross
trainers available in the US three
movements everyone should practice Jake
Earl described in the gymnast strong PDF
that accompanies this audio book
shoulder extension lift a dowel behind
your back standing or sit on the floor
and walk your hands backward behind your
hips thoracic bridge elevate your feet
enough to feel the bulk of the stretch
in the upper back and shoulders not the
lower back the feet might be 3 plus feet
off the ground ensure you can
concentrate on straightening your arms
and legs if possible holding the
position and breathing good goals for
adult non gymnasts the following goals
incorporate many different aspects of
strength and mobility into single
movements beginner Jay curl intermediate
straddle press handstand Tim Ferriss I'm
working on this advanced Stalder press
handstand sometimes
you just need a vibrator coach summer
introduced me to a Russian medical
massage specialist who recommended I use
the plug-in not cordless model of the
Hitachi Magic Wand on its high setting
I've never experienced such heights of
ecstasy thanks Vladimir just kidding in
this case it's for relaxing hypertonic
muscles ie muscles that are tense even
though they shouldn't be just place the
wand on your muscle belly not insertion
points for twenty to thirty seconds
which is often all it takes at the
proper Hertz tension headaches are a
stiff neck it's great for relaxing the
occipital z' at the base of the skull
warning
having Hitachi Magic Wand lying out
around your house can go terribly wrong
or terribly right good luck explaining
your hypertonic muscles as one friend
said to me I think my wife has that same
problem hey guys this is Tim again just
a few more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
and would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday and that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and 500 Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
[Applause]